welcome to another episode of unlocking
lily so I believe that we are all
capable of extraordinary things when we
embrace who we truly are Evans currently
an investor in my business and he's
helping me grow my coaching and speaking
practice and I am so incredibly honored
to have you guys join me on my startup
journey firing someone is the right
thing for them and if you're holding on
to an employee that you know that is not
right for the job or for your company
you are actually doing them way more
harm than good because even if they
tried their hardest and you tried your
hardest at the most they're only gonna
operate at a mediocre level when they
could be extraordinary somewhere else
and let's fast-forward this 10 15 20 30
50 years even down the road and they are
looking back in their career and they
plagued with regret because they wish
they had worked for a different company
that they could really fulfill their
potential and you as a leader who knew
what the right thing was and still did
not take action because of the fear of
hurting their feelings you are
responsible for that pain and I know
what you're thinking this is extremely
harsh what about their family I don't
want to hurt this person's feelings
maybe I'll just let this drag on a
little bit longer and I know this
firsthand because I have gone through
this myself I was struggling to take
action on this decision for the longest
time you see I hired my first employee a
little less than a year ago and he's one
of the nicest people you would ever meet
he really cared about people and he went
above and beyond
to help people out but after having
several conversations with him I
realized that the job was simply not
right for him he was so much bigger than
the job he had all this passion and
talent and skills inside of him that he
was just simply not utilizing at the
position he was in but I was afraid to
take action because I feared that I'm
gonna hurt his feelings and I wanted to
be nice so I drag this along for three
months justifying why I should keep him
around and I made excuses no maybes
because I moved to Thailand that's why
things are not working out that well
maybe it's a timezone difference maybe
is that they were all just excuses
because I was afraid and eventually I
realized the more I drag this on the
worst things got until eventually I had
to make that call and fire him so if
you're standing in the crossroads right
now and you are afraid to make the
decision and to take action I want to
help you because I don't want you to
struggle the way I did so I want to
share with you the three steps in firing
your employee step number one get into
the right mindset I understand that this
is the nicest thing you can do now
you're actually doing them a huge favor
by letting them go because now they
could go fulfil their potential where
they were only operating at ten percent
of their potential at your company and I
know it's going to hurt and it's going
to suck when you have that conversation
with them and feelings could potentially
get hurt and you may have a negative
impact on their families but know that
that pain is only temporary because in
the long run this is the best thing for
them so that's a mindset that I needed
to get into because as much as I'm
pushing you to do this I needed the
extra push myself because I was
justifying remember what I talked about
earlier
I just kept on
imagining my employee being somewhere
else that he could really shine as the
amazing person that he is I just kept on
looking forward and not worried about
the fear that was attached to it and the
more I did that it brought me more
clarity and focus so that way I could
actually take action towards doing the
right thing step number two have the
tough conversation it's called a tough
conversation for a reason because it's
not easy for anybody this is where your
love your compassion any empathy needs
to come in the whole reason why you're
struggling to finally take action on
this decision is because you were
concerned about their feelings and you
did not want to hurt them and that's
what you need to lead with you need to
lead with that much honesty and love and
that's what I did when I finally had
that conversation I told him that I was
worried about his feelings that he cared
so much for his job that I didn't want
him to think that he was doing a poor
job it was just not right for him and
the reason why I struggled so much is
because I was concerned about his family
because I know how hard it is when your
entire family is relying on your stable
income and I did not want to cause any
negative impact on his life and sure it
was really uncomfortable it was
uncomfortable for me it was
uncomfortable for him and maybe feelings
were hurt
temporary but in the long run this is
the best thing for everybody and that's
a thing having a tough conversation is
easily avoidable but in this situation
you can't you cannot avoid this because
this is your path in helping them out
step number three be supportive think
about all the different things that you
can do to help them in their transition
in getting
job so for example for me I hired my
employee threw up work so I made sure I
gave him a five-star review on his
profile I also gave him an awesome
feedback to show the future employers
how amazing he was and how much he cared
about his work and lastly I referred my
reference so anytime a future employer
wanted to contact me for reference I
would make myself available and that's
the thing you were struggling with this
decision is because you cared so much
about them so your support needs to
extend way beyond their employment with
you so guys those are my three steps and
I know how difficult it is to be an
entrepreneur and firing an employee it's
probably one of the hardest things you
will ever do so I'm hoping by me sharing
my journey and the mistakes that I have
made is going to help you and lessen
that pain a little bit
and I'm a social shadow for crafty Beach
thank you so much for reading the
comments in my last episode your support
means a lot to me and finally the
question of the day is what is the one
decision that you're struggling with
right now leave in the comments below
and I'll join in on the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching and more
importantly being on this journey with
me as I grow as I learn as I go through
my ups and my downs it gives me the
comfort in knowing that you guys aren't
there for me every step of the way
so thank you so much again and I'll see
you guys very very soon if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or that would
be kind of like a little beacon if you
want to keep up with Lily's adventures
check out the last video we did it's
right next to me I think you're gonna
enjoy continue to believe and I'll see
you there so living the extraordinary
life means that you're out there saying
yes to a bunch of different things and
following your curiosity and really
jumping into the unknown
you